Розкажи, що це за проєкт і взагалі.
Взагалі.
Спочатку...
Набагато важче перебратися з горба
на горб, ніж з рівнинного міста в інші.
Будь-які явища,
будь-які автентичні елементи
набагато краще зберігаються
у віддалених закутках гір,
ніж десь на рівнинних територіях.
Власне, Карпати мені видаються якраз тим
місцем, де дуже добре шукати по шпаринах.
— Доброго дня!
Яка у вас собака гарна!
Привіт, собако! Як його звати?
Як тебе звати? Це він. Га, Бастер?
Хороший. Бастер?
Мій проєкт називається «Carpathian Cult».
Мета його — дослідити локальну
культуру карпатського регіону
не тільки України,
а й в принципі закордоння.
І дослідження насамперед
базується на світлинах цієї місцевості,
світлинах із сімейних архівів його жителів.
Будем у хаті дивитися.
Фотографія — це факт існування
певного явища, людини.
Фотографії з того часу не могли,
наприклад, фотошопитись.
Вони приходять до нас крізь
віки такими, якими були,
і відображають момент,
зафіксований 20, 30, 50 років тому.
Фотографія, можна сказати, —
це насправді набагато більше,
ніж просто картинка.
Це ціла величезна історія.
Тут дуже багато фотографій. Я взагалі
не знаю, як це все опрацювати.
Дуже багато цікавих є.
Старих і не дуже.
Почалося все тоді, коли я волонтерила
на проєкті «Дідова хатчина».
І якось ми почали збирати фотографії,
щоб їх використовувати
в якихось колажах, для постерів.
Відповідно, ми почали з того,
що сканували фотографії наших сусідів.
Почала вести сторінку в інстаграмі
і туди заливати фотографії,
які я знаходила по сусідах, в мережі.
І тоді, коли у мене назбиралося
вже кілька сотень фотографій,
я просто подумала,
що було б класно їх показати світові.
Фіксація якихось побутових моментів,
історичних подій у житті села,
житті регіону, якісь обряди весільні,
похоронні, побутове життя —
багато що з цього уже не існує,
але його важливо запам'ятовувати
і розповідати про це.
Мами там є десь фотографія.
Вона була зв'язковою УПА.
Коли Вадік Дуб здався радянській владі,
а потім, на превеликий жаль,
система зламала його,
але багатьох він здав, багатьох після
нього було вислано у Сибір, Казахстан.
Мама втекла, і там якраз на фотографіях,
вона в село боялася приходити.
Оце якраз килим місцевого виробництва?
Це мамина фотографія.
Іноді це в традиційному сенсі експедиція,
коли я їду в певну місцевість,
шукаю фотографії, сканую їх.
Іноді фотографії приходять до мене самі.
Маю декілька своїх сторінок в інтернеті.
На одній мене якраз почали питатися,
і я буквально через кілька секунд
пишу, що я маю і можу надати.
Я по всіх сільських групах
району писала публікації
про те, що я оцифровую сімейні архіви,
особливо мене цікавлять села району.
І власне, з багатьох, кому я писала,
ви один з тих, хто відгукнувся.
Поки є можливість збирати
матеріали і знаходити людей,
які ще мають стосунок до свого коріння,
своїх гірських коренів,
то стараюсь щось сканувати, знаходити
людей, спілкуватися з ними,
тому що це вже трошки —
і первинні інформатори теж зникнуть.
Багато, на жаль, пропало.
Я пам'ятаю, що десь вони були,
а от де вони зараз є?
Пам'ять повинна бути збережена.
Історична культурна цінність повинна
передаватися з поколінння в покоління.
У мене немає задатків
приватних колекціонерів,
які коли щось знаходять,
то лишають тільки для себе,
собі любуються картинками, об'єктами.
Я більше за те, щоб отриманими
ресурсами ділитися.
Який тоді сенс колекціонувати все, якщо
воно лишається у власності однієї людини?
Коли я тільки почала ознайомлюватися
з архівами місцевості,
я відкрила для себе
дуже багато нових речей.
Зокрема, це стосується, наприклад,
якихось обрядових елементів, побуту,
якихось нюансів і історій про місцевість,
про людей, які тут жили.
— Добрий день!
Мене звати Христина.
Проходьте.
З точністю до району я можу
визначити локацію фотографії
завдяки одягу, який
вдягали люди на фотографії,
через якісь дрібні елементии,
наприклад, тип вишиття чи нижній одяг.
Дуже багато є дрібних нюансів,
за якими можна відрізнити,
з якої це місцевості, з якого це року,
якого статку була ця людина.
Жінки нашого села носили такі довгі фартухи
на спідниці, що називалося «шальон».
— Ніби шальова тканина.
— Так, так. Ні, не шальова — шальон.
Ага, сам фартух.
У таких спідницях виходили заміж,
їх зберігали протягом життя,
навіть коли помирала жінка,
її переважно в них хоронили.
Хустка шалянова була
як цінність того часу, мабуть.
Не кожна могла собі дозволити.
Мені вдалося позбирати багато
фотографій з різних регіонів.
Наразі в мене, здається, більше
трьох з половиною тисяч фотографій.
Переважно це Гуцульщина,
частина Буковини,
є буквально кілька Закарпаття,
трішки Бойківщини.
— Ця вже дуже стара.
— Це виглядає ніби 20-ті роки.
Це моя бабця, Євдокія Онуфріївна.
А це, мабуть, якась її подружка.
Так цікаво, щось у неї щось на шиї,
але не подібне на силянку.
Мене вже питали, чому я досліджую
лише карпатський регіон.
Насамперед мені здається, що
це завелика робота для мене
і я за те, щоб з'являлися інші люди,
які б досліджували власні регіони.
Я досліджую те, що мені близьке
географічно, культурно, логістично,
і те, що я розумію.
Тобто, коли я їду по району
і кажу, що я з Надвірної,
для людей я автоматично стаю сусідкою,
людиною, якій вони більше довіряють,
яку більше розуміють.
Для мене це вже
останній цикл сканування.
Ваша дочка казала, що у вас мало
фотографій, а у вас дуже багато цікавих.
То не всі, повірте, ще дуже багато є.
Але ж вас просто ці зацікавили.
Насправді купа фотографій є.
Але ніхто не думав,
зараз переважно носії вже інші.
Просто якось вони зацікавили,
лишали, якась пам'ять.
Неймовірно важлива частина
мого життя — це місцевість, де я виросла,
де я прожила частину свого життя, куди я
завжди верталася, і хотілося її висвітлити.
Я не була б готова
змінити місце проживання,
я не готова була б жити десь,
де немає моїх рідних гір,
і десь, де немає мого рідного
місця в близькій доступності.
Я трохи досліджувала
власні сімейні архіви.
Наприклад, я дізналася про таку
цікаву особу, як баба Марта.
А історія була така, що вона
ніби працювала в полі
і до неї приставав один з вищих
за званням і до того ж з партійних робочих.
Задля оборони вона його огріла
лопатою, якщо я не помиляюсь, по вусі,
за що він на неї дуже образився і
грозився її вислати далеко та надовго.
І аби вберегтися від цього,
вона продала коней, особисті речі
і втекла на добрий десяток
років у село Бистриця.
По суті, переховувалася від
цих партійних чинуш,
щоб не потрапити до них у руки
і не поїхати далеко і надовго,
оскільки в неї були діти, родина.
Ну і приблизно через десяток років вона
повернулася назад у місто, до родини,
коли черговий режим змінився
і все стабілізувалось,
наскільки це могло бути в той час.
Дуже багато людей, які зазнали певних
репресій, не схильні про це розповідати,
навіть через десятки років,
бо це для них або травматично, або вони
мають певне тіньове відчуття страху
через те, що на той час це було
дуже боляче, дуже страшно
і, власне, про ці історії часто не
розповідають, але вони існують.
Хотілось би присвячувати весь робочий
час дослідженням, експедиціям,
але по факту, кожен третій день я
займаюся публікацією матеріалів,
я обробляю якісь фотографії,
і кожен третій день, згідно контент-плану
— все вже дуже серйозно —
я займаюсь проєктом.
Існує Patreon, де, хоч небагато людей,
але вони готові донатити
на підтримку і розвиток проєкту.
Я вважаю, що це дуже
хороший показник того,
що навіть такі специфічні,
не зовсім розважальні,
не зовсім типові медійні проєкти можуть
мати все-таки якусь фінансову підтримку,
а це означає, що вони є актуальними.
Мені дуже важливо спрямовувати свою
енергію на розширення досліджень,
актуалізацію традиційної культури
і я бачу, що у людей є до цього фідбек,
і це також мотивує мене продовжувати
і в майбутньому хотілось би бути, напевно,
гордою етнографісткою-дослідницею,
але без ступеню, без всяких
особливих почестей,
— просто людиною, яка займається тим,
що їй подобається і живе з цього.
Я думаю, це би було хороше майбутнє.